I didn't really know this growing up but
some people believe that Halloween is
unchristian but that is not true at all
Halloween is a Christian Festival
because Halloween is the night before
All Saints Day so it's all Hallow's Eve
and then All Saints Day is a an ancient
uh Christian celebration for all the
saints who are up in heaven so uh
Halloween is very good you don't want to
go out into the woods and worship demons
and stuff you know but you don't want to
do that any day of the week like on a
Tuesday or Wednesday or Halloween none
none on none of those days should you do
that but if you want to dress up and eat
some delicious jeries chocolate that is
totally fine